- Vítej zpět u kurzu Porozumění kvantovým
informacím a výpočtům.
Jmenuji se John Watrous a
jsem technický ředitel pro IBM Quantum Education.
Toto je šestá lekce série a zároveň druhá lekce
druhé části série, která se věnuje kvantovým algoritmům.
V předchozí lekci jsme probírali dotazovací
model výpočtu a viděli jsme, že v tomto modelu mohou kvantové algoritmy poskytnout výraznou výhodu
oproti klasickým algoritmům, včetně exponenciální výhody v případě Simonova problému.
Dotazovací model bohužel
nemá žádnou přímou ani okamžitou
praktickou relevanci.
Pojem černé skříňky je velmi užitečná
abstrakce, jak se ukazuje, ale musíme ještě trochu zapracovat, pokud chceme uplatnit
poznatky, které jsme
získali z dotazovacího modelu, ve standardnějším výpočetním prostředí, kde jsou vstupy zadávány jako řetězce bitů
spíše než jako orákula nebo černé skříňky.
Hlavním účelem této lekce je vytvořit základ,
ze kterého toho budeme moci dosáhnout.
Zde je přehled lekce. Velkou část lekce se budeme zaměřovat
na výpočetní náklady,
jinými slovy, jak náročné jsou různé
výpočetní úlohy a jak tuto náročnost měřit.
Zhruba řečeno, to se promítá do toho, jak dlouho musíme čekat
na dokončení výpočtů a v konečném důsledku které
výpočetní problémy
dokážeme vyřešit a které
jsou mimo naše možnosti.
Začneme
několika příklady. Celočíselná faktorizace a výpočet největšího společného
dělitele, zkráceně NSD.
To jsou velmi dobré příklady pro ilustraci
základních principů a oba navíc
mají velký vztah ke Shorovu algoritmu, o kterém budeme
mluvit v příští lekci,
takže z těchto příkladů
vytěžíme dvojí užitek.
Poté si probereme pojem výpočetních nákladů obecněji a jak je měřit.
Existuje mnoho různých
způsobů, jak to udělat, ale zaměříme se poměrně úzce na to, jak to zvládnout pomocí circuit modelů výpočtu,
konkrétně Booleovských circuit
a kvantových circuit.
Zaměřením jsou zde algoritmy, nikoli například počítačový
hardware, a více nás zajímá
to, jak se náklady
na spuštění algoritmu škálují s tím, jak rostou konkrétní instance problémů, na nichž běží, spíše než to, kolik sekund,
minut nebo hodin
konkrétní výpočet vyžaduje.
Myšlenka, která stojí za tímto pohledem, je taková, že algoritmy mají
zásadní důležitost.
Dodnes
stále používáme algoritmy, které byly vyvinuty
před velmi, velmi dlouhou dobou a zcela přirozeně budou nasazovány
na stále
větší instance problémů s využitím rychlejšího a spolehlivějšího hardwaru, jak se technologie vyvíjejí.
A způsob, jakým se škálují, nám říká hodně
o tom, jak užitečné jsou a jak užitečné budou i nadále.
V poslední části lekce se obrátíme ke kriticky důležitému úkolu, kterým je provádění klasických výpočtů
na kvantových počítačích. Důvodem, proč je to důležité, není to, že doufáme v nahrazení klasických počítačů
kvantovými,
což se zdá být velmi nepravděpodobné v dohledné době, pokud k tomu vůbec dojde, ale spíše proto, že to otevírá
mnoho zajímavých možností
pro kvantové algoritmy.
Konkrétně, jakmile víme, jak spouštět klasické výpočty
na kvantových počítačích, stávají se dostupnými pro kvantové
algoritmy jako podrutiny
a můžeme tak efektivně
využít vše, co víme o klasických algoritmech, při hledání kvantových výpočetních výhod.
Klasické počítače, které máme dnes, jsou skutečnými zázraky technologie.
Jsou neuvěřitelně rychlé, ale ne tak rychlé, že by žádný výpočetní problém
nebyl mimo jejich dosah.
Některé výpočetní problémy
jsou ze své podstaty tak obtížné, že přestože algoritmy k jejich řešení existují, žádný počítač na planetě Zemi dnes
není dostatečně rychlý, aby tyto
algoritmy doběhly do konce i na středně velkých vstupech za dobu lidského života
nebo dokonce za dobu
existence samotné Země.
Abychom to lépe vysvětlili, podívejme se na
problém celočíselné faktorizace.
Zadání problému je velmi jednoduché. Vstupem problému je celé číslo N, které je alespoň dvě, a výstupem je
prvočíselný rozklad N,
přičemž to znamená seznam prvočíselných dělitelů N spolu s mocniteli, na které musí být tato prvočísla umocněna,
abychom jejich vynásobením
dostali N.
Prvočíselné dělitele samozřejmě můžeme vždy násobit v libovolném pořadí, ale jinak než pořadím
jsou prvočíselné rozklady pro každou volbu N vždy jedinečné.
Tento fakt se nazývá
základní věta aritmetiky a pokud tě
to zajímá a chceš se o tom dozvědět více, najdeš to
hned na začátku
mnoha knih o teorii čísel.
Jako velmi jednoduchý příklad si uveď prvočíselný rozklad
čísla 12.
Je to dvě na druhou
krát tři na první.
WEBVTT
Není překvapením, že ti to
počítač řekne mrknutím oka pouhým iterativním hledáním
prvočíselných dělitelů.
Tady je další příklad. Číst toto číslo se nebudu pokoušet.
Je to přibližně 3,4 kvattuordecilionů a musím přiznat, že mi připadá zvláštní, že takovýto název vůbec existuje,
ale každopádně, má 46 desetinných číslic a tady vidíš
jeho prvočíselný rozklad.
Počítač ti to také řekne. Toto číslo jsem faktorizoval pomocí metody faktorizace obsažené v knihovně pro symbolickou matematiku pro Python,
a zabralo to několik sekund, což není příliš dlouho, ale byl tam znatelný prodlev.
Metoda factor_N rozhodně nenajde tento prvočíselný rozklad naivním hledáním prvočíselných dělitelů.
Ve skutečnosti využívá hybrid
různých algoritmů, včetně jednoho zvaného
algoritmus barevných řádků, což je algoritmus pro faktorizaci,
který je propracovanější než naivní iterativní
hledání prvočíselných dělitelů, a přestože se může zdát
jako poměrně velké číslo,
jako vstup výpočetního problému není ve skutečnosti příliš velké.
Je to jen 46 znaků.
Tady je ještě jeden příklad. Je to číslo s 309 desetinnými číslicemi.
Pokud ho zapíšeme v binárním zápisu, má 1 024 bitů a
proto se jmenuje RSA1024.
Prvočíselný rozklad tohoto čísla není v současnosti znám.
Toto číslo pochází z
RSA faktoringové výzvy, kterou provozovaly RSA
Laboratories od roku 1991 do roku 2007.
Nabízely peněžní odměny
za prvočíselné rozklady různých čísel rostoucí
velikosti, včetně tohoto, které mělo hodnotu 100 000 USD,
ale tato odměna nebyla nikdy vyplacena.
Bezpečnost kryptosystému RSA
s veřejným klíčem je založena na obtížnosti
celočíselné faktorizace.
Pokud umíš faktorizovat, dokážeš
systém prolomit, a proto byl účelem výzvy v podstatě sledování
nejmodernějšího stavu faktorizace.
Závěr je, že
faktorizace tohoto čísla přesahuje naše současné schopnosti.
Pokud je nám známo, je
samotný problém příliš složitý na to, aby ho klasické počítače
v praxi vyřešily.
Největší RSA výzva, která byla dosud faktorizována, mimochodem obsahuje 250 desetinných číslic.
Na obrazovce to může být trochu
špatně čitelné, ale tady je prvočíselný
rozklad RSA250.
Byl proveden v roce 2020 pomocí algoritmu známého jako síto číselného pole a jednalo se o kolektivní úsilí zahrnující desítky tisíc
počítačů po celém světě.
Nyní se podívejme na jiný
výpočetní problém, kterým je problém výpočtu největšího společného
dělitele, zkráceně NSD,
dvou nezáporných celých čísel.
Zde je zadání problému. Vstup se tentokrát skládá ze dvou
čísel, N a M,
a budeme předpokládat, že
obě nejsou zároveň rovna nule.
Cílem je vypočítat
NSD těchto dvou čísel, což je největší celé číslo D, které dělí beze zbytku jak N, tak M,
a pokud si představíš
prvočíselné rozklady N a M, zjistíš, že NSD je součin všech prvočísel,
která dělí jak N, tak M, umocněných na minimum mocnitelů, které se vyskytují ve dvou
prvočíselných rozkladech.
Takže to souvisí s problémem
celočíselné faktorizace, ale ukazuje se, že to je mnohem, mnohem jednodušší
pro počítače k řešení. NSD čísel s mnoha tisíci číslic dokážeme vypočítat
mrknutím oka.
Ukazovat ti příklady na obrazovce by bylo zbytečné, protože bychom mohli zaplnit
celou obrazovku číslicemi a stále bychom popisovali
snadno řešitelné instance tohoto problému.
Ale pokud tě to zajímá, klikni na odkaz v popisu videa na stránku učebnice pro tuto lekci a najdeš tam buňky s kódem
pro typy výpočtů,
o kterých mluvím, včetně těch, které počítají
NSD velkých čísel, a můžeš je sám vyzkoušet.
Otázka zní, proč je výpočet NSD tak snadný?
A odpověď na tuto otázku je, že máme efektivní
algoritmy pro výpočet NSD.
Mezi nimi je Eukleidův algoritmus, který byl objeven před více než 2 000 lety, ale existují také jiné
efektivní algoritmy NSD.
A samozřejmě mluvíme zde o klasických algoritmech, takže to vede k další otázce.
Mohl by existovat efektivní
klasický algoritmus pro celočíselnou faktorizaci,
který by nám umožnil faktorizovat čísla jako RSA1024
mrknutím oka?
A odpověď je ano. Absolutně by mohl existovat efektivní klasický
algoritmus pro faktorizaci a v současnosti neznáme žádný způsob,
jak tuto možnost vyloučit. Vše, co můžeme říct, je, že
jsme ho zatím nenašli.
Přes všechny klasické
faktorizační algoritmy, které známe, stále v podstatě
hledáme dělitele
a to staví čísla jako
RSA1024 mimo náš dosah.
Efektivní algoritmy NSD,
na druhou stranu, takto nefungují.
Nehledají největšího
společného dělitele. Efektivně ho jen konstruují mechanickým postupem, jehož náklady jsou přibližně srovnatelné s náklady
na vynásobení stejných
dvou čísel, a o tom si řeknu trochu více dále v lekci.
WEBVTT
To vše samozřejmě směřuje
k Shorovu algoritmu, který uvidíme v příští lekci a který je efektivním kvantovým algoritmem
pro výpočet prvočíselných rozkladů, ale ještě máme nějaký terén k pokrytí, než se tam dostaneme.
Dále si budeme povídat
o matematickém rámci, skrze který můžeme měřit výpočetní náklady
různých algoritmů,
včetně těch, o kterých jsme již mluvili.
Jasně, zaměříme se velmi úzce na circuit, což je jen malý kousek
mnohem širšího tématu.
Začněme pohledem na velmi vysoké úrovni na běžný výpočet
z předchozí lekce, přičemž konkrétně tím myslíme, že nepřemýšlíme
o dotazovacích problémech,
ale o problémech,
kde je vstup zadán explicitně jako binární řetězec.
Jak jsem řekl v předchozí lekci, samozřejmě bychom mohli
povolit i jiné symboly, kdybychom chtěli, ale pojďme to zjednodušit a držet se binárních řetězců
jak pro vstup, tak pro výstup.
Samotný výpočet by mohl být modelován nebo popsán různými způsoby, například pomocí Turingova
strojového modelu výpočtu,
Booleovských circuit, kvantových circuit nebo programů napsaných
v jazyce jako Python nebo v jakémkoli jiném jazyce dle tvé volby.
Jak jsem před chvílí řekl, zaměříme se na
circuit, Booleovské a kvantové.
Nejprve věnujme trochu více času povídání o vstupu a výstupu, o nichž předpokládáme, že jsou binárními řetězci.
Pomocí binárních řetězců můžeme kódovat mnoho různých druhů
matematických objektů, jako jsou čísla, vektory,
matice, grafy,
popisy molekul, například, stejně jako seznamy všech těchto objektů a dalších.
Jako velmi jednoduchý příklad, pokud chceme kódovat nezáporné
celé číslo jako binární řetězce, můžeme použít binární zápis.
V této tabulce uvidíš prvních 13
nezáporných celých čísel spolu s jejich binárními
reprezentacemi nebo kódováními.
Ve třetím sloupci vidíš délku
každého z těchto kódování, což je jen celkový počet bitů potřebných pro kódování,
a zde je jednoduchý vzorec, který ti přesně říká, kolik bitů
je obecně potřeba pro jakékoli nezáporné celé číslo N.
Všimni si zejména, že
délka kódování je obecně mnohem menší
než samotné číslo.
Je logaritmická v čísle.
RSA1024 má například kódování o délce 1 024, ale samotné číslo je
samozřejmě mnohem větší.
Toto kódovací schéma funguje
pro nezáporná celá čísla, ale pokud chceme zpracovávat
libovolná celá čísla, včetně záporných, můžeme jednoduše přidat znaménkový bit.
Můžeme také v těchto kódováních dovolit libovolný počet úvodních nul, pokud chceme, aby kódování
vyplňovala blok bitů nebo registr pevné velikosti,
pokud je dostatečně velký. Někdy je to velmi pohodlné.
Toto není jediný způsob, jak kódovat celá čísla jako řetězce bitů.
Existují i jiné způsoby, jak to udělat, ale toto je poměrně
standardní způsob.
Pro jiné druhy objektů, které mohou tvořit vstupy nebo výstupy výpočetních
problémů, které nás zajímají, můžeme přijít s
jinými kódovacími schématy.
Přemýšlej například o tom,
jak bys mohl zakódovat vektor nebo graf jako binární řetězec, nebo o tom, jak bys mohl zakódovat
dva binární řetězce do
jednoho binárního řetězce, přičemž bys použil jen symbol nula a jedna bez mezery nebo jiného symbolu
pro oddělení dvou řetězců. Jsou tu jistě způsoby, jak
to provést, a ve skutečnosti máme velkou svobodu
v tom, jak přesně to udělat.
Často neexistuje jediný standardní nebo obecně dohodnutý způsob kódování čehokoli, o čem mluvíme,
jako binárního řetězce,
ale to je v pořádku, můžeme si prostě vybrat jeden nebo vynaleznou nový, pokud dáváme přednost.
Z čistě formálního hlediska přemýšlíme o výpočtech v podstatě jako o mechanických transformacích řetězců bitů
a specifika jakýchkoli
kódovacích schémat, která používáme, jsou na určité úrovni jistě důležitá.
Přesto při navrhování a
analýze algoritmů se obvykle příliš nestaráme o specifika
kódovacích schémat.
Pokud požádáš dva různé lidi, aby přišli se způsobem kódování, řekněme, molekul určitého
druhu jako binárních řetězců,
možná od nich očekáváš, že přijdou s různými způsoby, jak to udělat, ale pokud by to byli rozumní lidé, kteří vědí, co dělají,
mohl bys také přiměřeně očekávat, že překlad tam a zpět mezi dvěma kódovacími schématy by byl poměrně
jednoduchý výpočetní proces,
který by s největší pravděpodobností vyžadoval velmi
přímočarý výpočet, jenž by byl docela snadný ve srovnání se skutečným výpočtem,
který nás zajímá.
Závěr je, že podrobnosti o kódovacích schématech, která používáme, jsou často zcela druhořadé a naše zaměření je na samotné algoritmy.
Toto mimochodem nebude v této lekci problémem. Budeme se hlavně zaměřovat na problémy, které se týkají celých čísel, o nichž budeme předpokládat, že jsou kódována binárně,
ale je to něco, na co je dobré myslet.
Obecně, pro jakýkoli druh problému, o kterém mluvíme, délka vstupu označuje
počet bitů potřebných k zakódování vstupu,
a délku vstupu považujeme za velikost instance jakéhokoli problému, o kterém přemýšlíme.
Nyní si vezměme
samotný výpočet, který je reprezentován
modrým obdélníkem v tomto obrázku.
Způsob, jakým budeme
měřit náklady tohoto výpočtu, je počítání počtu elementárních operací, které vyžaduje.
Intuitivně řečeno, elementární operace je taková, která zahrnuje malý fixní
počet bitů nebo qubitů
a lze ji provést rychle a snadno, jako výpočet logického AND
dvou bitů, například.
WEBVTT
Na formální úrovni
existují různé způsoby, jak definovat, co je elementární operace, v závislosti na tom, jaký
výpočetní model používáme.
Například elementární operace by mohla být jedním krokem Turingova stroje, pokud bychom používali tento model.
Pro účely této lekce se budeme zaměřovat na circuit modely, jak jsem již uvedl, a konkrétně na kvantové
a Booleovské circuit.
Při práci s circuit je typické, že každý gate považujeme za elementární operaci.
V sérii jsme dosud viděli několik různých kvantových gate,
včetně X, Y a Z gate, Hadamard gate, S a T gate,
controlled NOT gate, swap gate, Toffoli gate a Fredkin gate.
Mluvili jsme také o query gate v kontextu dotazovacího modelu, ale v této lekci nebudeme v dotazovacím modelu pracovat, takže si nemusíme dělat starosti s
query gate prozatím.
Viděli jsme také, že jakoukoli unitární operaci na libovolném počtu qubitů
lze považovat za gate, pokud to chceme.
Pro účely měření nákladů to však nebude příliš užitečné, takže to, co uděláme, je jednoduše vybereme sadu gate
a tuto sadu budeme považovat za naši sadu elementárních operací.
Nejprve zahrneme
jednoqubitové unitární gate, které vidíš zde,
jmenovitě X, Y a Z gate,
Hadamard gate a S a T gate, stejně jako jejich inverzy
nebo sdružené transponáty.
Vlastně nepotřebujeme všechny tyto gate. Jakmile máme Hadamard a T gate, dokážeme implementovat ostatní,
ale jen pro pohodlí zahrneme všechny.
Zahrneme také controlled NOT gate a to budou jediné
vícequbitové gate v naší sadě.
A nakonec zahrneme jednoqubitová standardní bazová měření, abychom z našich circuit
mohli skutečně získat klasické informace.
Pokud se zaměříme pouze na unitární gate a zapomeneme na chvíli
na měření, získáme to, čemu se říká
universální sada gate.
To znamená, že
jakákoli unitární operace na libovolném počtu qubitů může
být implementována buď přesně
nebo libovolně přesně
kvantovým circuit postaveným pouze z těchto gate.
Jinými slovy, toto je
dostatečně dobrá sada gate, ze které dokážeme sestrojit jakoukoli unitární
operaci.
Ne nutně přesně, ale dokážeme dosáhnout tak dobré
aproximace, jakou chceme.
To může vyžadovat hodně gate a vlastně není příliš obtížné zdůvodnit, že to někdy hodně gate vyžadovat musí,
ale přesto je to vždy možné.
Není jednoduché dokázat, že toto je universální sada gate, a v sérii se nebudeme bavit o tom,
jak se to dělá,
ale je to poměrně dobře známý fakt a ve skutečnosti existují různé
způsoby, jak to lze dokázat.
Existují také jiné sady gate, které se někdy používají
místo této, například Toffoli gate, Hadamard gate a S gate kromě měření,
ale toto je poměrně standardní volba.
Tedy souhrnně, to jsou
kvantové operace, které budeme považovat za elementární.
Pro Booleovské circuit
budeme považovat tyto čtyři gate za
elementární operace: AND gate, OR gate, NOT gate a FANOUT.
FANOUT mimochodem není
vždy počítán jako gate, ale pro nás bude
důležité to tak dělat, jak uvidíme později v lekci.
Podobně jako u naší standardní sady kvantových gate je tato sada trochu redundantní.
Nepotřebuješ zároveň AND i OR. Každý z nich můžeš vytvořit pomocí druhého se třemi NOT gate,
ale nevadí zahrnout oba a je to jen pohodlné.
Jak možná již víš, toto je universální sada gate
pro deterministické výpočty, což znamená, že jakákoli funkce
z bitů na bity
může být implementována Booleovským circuit složeným z gate z této kolekce.
Opět, stejně jako u
kvantových circuit, to neznamená, že každou funkci lze efektivně implementovat
Booleovským circuit,
a vskutku většinu funkcí
lze implementovat pouze pomocí velmi velkých circuit
z prostého důvodu, že existuje hodně a hodně funkcí
a ne všechny mohou mít malé circuit. Prostě není dost
malých circuit pro všechny.
Universalita je v tomto případě snazší
dokázat než v kvantovém případě.
Takže pokud to ještě
nevíš, jak dokázat, zamysli se nad tím a
zkus přijít na to, pokud máš chuť.
Nyní, když jsme se rozhodli pro
gate, které budeme povolovat a které budeme považovat
za elementární operace, můžeme přemýšlet o tom, kolik jich
je potřeba k provádění
různých výpočtů.
K tomu využijeme
tuto definici pro velikost circuit.
Tato definice funguje jak pro
Booleovské, tak pro kvantové circuit a je velmi jednoduchá.
Velikost circuit je celkový
počet gate, které obsahuje.
Například, pokud se vrátíme
ke stejnému příkladu, který jsme viděli několikrát, což je náš Booleovský circuit pro výpočet výlučného OR dvou bitů,
vidíme, že má velikost sedm,
protože obsahuje sedm gate, dva FANOUT gate, dva NOT gate,
dva AND gate a jeden OR gate. Pokud bychom se rozhodli nepočítat
FANOUT gate, což je běžné, měl by velikost pět,
ale FANOUT gate budeme počítat, takže jeho velikost je sedm.
WEBVTT
Velikost circuit
odpovídá počtu elementárních operací,
které musíme provést.
Takže pokud bychom tyto
operace prováděli sekvenčně, velikost by nám říkala,
jak dlouho by to trvalo,
takže velikost circuit si lze představit jako sekvenční dobu běhu.
Takto budeme měřit výpočetní náklady pro účely této lekce.
Existuje však ještě další vlastnost
circuit, která může být také považována za množství času
potřebného ke spuštění circuit, a to je hloubka circuit.
Přesněji řečeno, hloubka
je maximální počet gate, se kterými se setkáme na jakékoli cestě od vstupního drátu k výstupnímu drátu,
což je ekvivalentní počtu vrstev gate potřebných
k vytvoření circuit, kde vrstva označuje skupinu gate,
které lze provádět současně, protože nemají
žádné společné dráty.
Například náš circuit
z dřívějška má hloubku čtyři a přímo z diagramu vidíme, že jsou čtyři vrstvy.
FANOUT gate lze
provádět současně, NOT gate lze
provádět současně a AND gate lze
rovněž provádět současně.
Takže hloubku circuit si lze představit jako paralelní dobu běhu.
Hloubka circuit je jistě zajímavý a důležitý pojem a existují velmi
propracované techniky, které lze použít ke snížení
hloubky potřebné pro některé výpočty, někdy poměrně dramaticky, ale je to pokročilé téma
a v této sérii o tom nebudeme příliš mluvit.
Takže znovu, budeme
měřit výpočetní náklady z hlediska velikosti circuit,
jinými slovy,
počtu elementárních operací potřebných k provedení výpočtu.
Na začátku lekce jsme mluvili o problému
celočíselné faktorizace a viděli jsme, že čas potřebný pro algoritmus k řešení tohoto problému
může narůstat s tím, jak rostou vstupy, a to je typicky
problém, na který se zaměřujeme
při analýze algoritmů.
To jest, zajímá nás, jak se náklady na provoz algoritmů škálují s tím, jak vstupy rostou.
Toto škálování samozřejmě není jediná věc, na které záleží.
Například nás může jednoduše zajímat nalezení dělitelů
RSA1024 a nic jiného.
Takže v takovém případě bychom mluvili o
jedné instanci problému, kde nic neroste.
Ale když přemýšlíme o algoritmech, způsob, jakým jejich náklady
škálují, je velmi důležitý a říká nám hodně
o algoritmech.
Tento pohled je
v souladu s myšlenkou, že algoritmy jsou fundamentální, a jak jsem říkal dříve,
jak čas plyne a technologie se vyvíjejí, budou nasazovány na
stále větší vstupy.
Ale všimni si, že zatímco vstupy výpočetních problémů
mohou růst, circuit neroste.
Každý circuit má pevnou velikost.
A z toho důvodu, pokud chceme popsat
algoritmus pomocí circuit, budeme vlastně potřebovat rodinu circuit,
a rodinou circuit rozumíme kolekci circuit, která je stále větší, abychom mohli pojmout vstupy,
jak jsou stále větší. Zvažme například klasický deterministický algoritmus
pro problém celočíselné faktorizace, možná jeden založený na zkusmém dělení, ale konkrétní detaily pro tento příklad nezáleží.
pro tento příklad.
Mohli bychom v principu
popsat takový algoritmus pomocí rodiny Booleovských circuit, kde pro faktorizaci čísla,
jehož binární reprezentace má N bitů, vybereme circuit CN z naší rodiny a na vstupní bity tohoto circuit zadáme číslo,
které chceme faktorizovat,
do vstupních bitů tohoto circuit.
Někdy bychom mohli zvolit parametrizaci těchto
circuit různými způsoby, takže nemusí vždy platit, že N-tý circuit má N vstupních bitů,
ale je to poměrně typický způsob. Přirozeně, s tím, jak se délky vstupů prodlužují, bychom očekávali, že circuit
v této rodině budou větší,
čímž se odráží fakt, že
faktorizace čtyřbitových čísel je mnohem snazší než faktorizace 1 024bitových čísel.
A tak s tím na mysli měříme náklady takového
algoritmu funkcí, která nám říká, kolik
elementárních operací
potřebujeme pro každou možnou délku vstupu, a to zvládneme pro klasické i kvantové algoritmy.
Jako příklad vezměme problém celočíselného sčítání, který je jistě mnohem
jednodušší než faktorizace
nebo dokonce výpočet NSD.
Pro jednoduchost předpokládejme, že N i
M jsou nezáporná celá čísla a jsou reprezentována
binárními řetězci stejné délky.
Jak bychom mohli sestavit Booleovské circuit, které sečtou tato dvě čísla?
Začněme algoritmem, standardním algoritmem pro sčítání, což je dvouková analogie metody,
o které předpokládám, že jsme se všichni naučili sčítat čísla
tužkou a papírem, takže začneme s
nejméně významnými bity,
sečteme je dohromady a to nám dá nejméně
významný bit výsledku spolu s přenosovým bitem,
který musíme zvážit
při přesunu na další pozici. A pokračujeme v procházení bity, generujeme výstupní bity
spolu s přenosovými bity,
dokud se nedostaneme na konec.
WEBVTT
Tuto metodu lze
poměrně přímo vyjádřit pomocí Booleovských circuit.
Jedním ze způsobů, jak to přemyslet, je začít malým circuit pro sčítání dvou jednobitwých celých čísel.
To nám dá číslo
mezi nulou a dvěma, kde méně významný bit je XOR vstupních bitů
a více významný bit, nebo přenosový bit chceš-li, je AND dvou vstupních bitů.
Někdy označujeme circuit, který provádí tyto
dvě operace dohromady, jako poloscčítačka.
To funguje dobře, když
jsou jen dva vstupní bity, ale pokud chceme sčítat celá čísla s více než jedním bitem,
budeme muset nějak
zpracovat přenosové bity.
Takže co můžeme udělat, je kaskádovitě spojit
dvě poloscčítačky a vzít OR přenosových
bitů, které produkují, čímž vytvoříme tzv. úplnou sčítačku,
což je v podstatě Booleovský circuit pro sčítání tří jednobitwých
čísel dohromady.
A jakmile máme úplnou sčítačku, můžeme sčítat čísla
jednoduše kaskádováním, přičemž postupujeme od nejméně významného bitu
k nejvíce významnému bitu. V podstatě jen implementujeme standardní algoritmus sčítání pomocí úplných sčítaček k
zpracování přenosových bitů.
Jaké jsou tedy náklady tohoto výpočtu?
Potřebujeme sedm elementárních
gate pro každý XOR gate, což znamená 10 gate pro poloscčítačku
a tedy 21 gate pro úplnou sčítačku, což jsou dvě poloscčítačky plus OR gate.
Takže na konci, pokud mají naše vstupní čísla obě AND bitů, potřebujeme poloscčítačku pro
nejméně významný bit
a úplnou sčítačku pro každý další bit, přičemž výsledek je 21 krát N minus jedna plus 10 nebo celkem 21 N minus 11 gate.
Kdybychom se z nějakého důvodu rozhodli
nepočítat FANOUT gate a zahrnuli XOR
gate do naší sady gate, potřebovali bychom celkem pět N minus
tři gate.
Je hezké vědět přesně, kolik gate nebo elementárních operací je potřeba k provádění různých výpočtů,
jak jsme viděli u celočíselného sčítání.
A samozřejmě, pokud chceme tyto výpočty skutečně implementovat, musíme tyto podrobnosti znát.
Ale pokud vždy půjdeme do takových podrobností, zvláště u složitějších
algoritmů, budeme se velmi rychle utopit v detailech,
které jsou v mnoha případech
druhotného významu.
Jedním ze způsobů, jak zjednodušit záležitosti, který je velmi běžný při
analýze algoritmů, je využití notace big-O,
která nám umožňuje vyjadřovat
a porovnávat rychlosti růstu poměrně jednoduchým způsobem,
který je velmi pohodlný.
A zde vidíš definici, která stojí za touto notací.
Předpokládejme, že máme
dvě funkce G a H, které pro jednoduchost budeme považovat za přijímající hodnoty nezáporných celých čísel,
ačkoli to ve skutečnosti není vyžadováno. G a H možná reprezentují náklady různých výpočtů, například.
Pak říkáme, že G je big-O od H, což se tradičně zapisuje
se znaménkem rovnosti takto.
Pokud G(N) je nejvýše nějaká
kladná konstanta C krát H(N), pokud je N dostatečně velké.
Jde tedy o to, co
se stane, když N bude velké.
Formálně, co „dostatečně velké" znamená, je, že existuje nějaká volba N nula, tak že nerovnost platí
vždy, když N je alespoň N nula.
Klíčem je, že tato
čísla C a N nula jsou fixní.
Mohou to být jakákoli čísla,
ale ať jsou jakákoli, nemohou se měnit s tím, jak N roste.
Pokud jsi tuto
definici nikdy předtím neviděl, může trvat než si zvykneš, a lze najít zdroje,
které tento koncept vysvětlí
mnohem podrobněji,
než jsem schopen v této lekci.
Obvykle co děláme, je zvolit
funkci H tak, aby byla jednoduchá, abychom vyjádřili něco o tom, jak rychle roste funkce G.
Například funkce, jejíž hodnota je 17 krát N na třetí minus 257
krát N na druhou plus
65 537 je big-O od N na třetí, a tento příklad
lze přizpůsobit definici
vhodnou volbou C a N nula.
Například pokud vezmeme C rovné 18, pak bude
výraz skutečně nejvýše 18 krát N na třetí,
pokud je N dostatečně velké.
Propojením této notace zpět
s příkladem celočíselného sčítání, co nyní můžeme říct, je, že existuje rodina Booleovských circuit
pro sčítání nezáporných celých čísel, tak že velikost N-tého circuit, tj. toho, který funguje
pro vstupy délky N,
je big-O od N. Skutečná velikost CN
podle naší analýzy byla 21 krát N minus 11,
ale to je big-O od N.
Nemusí být vždy chytré zahazovat podrobnosti takhle, ale zde to dává smysl,
protože to odhaluje podstatnou povahu standardního algoritmu sčítání, která spočívá v tom, že jeho náklady škálují lineárně
s velikostí čísel,
která sčítáme, a tento výraz není citlivý na některé nízkoúrovňové
detaily našeho modelu,
jako například přesně které gate považujeme za elementární operace.
Například, kdybychom se rozhodli, že XOR gate by měly být považovány za
elementární operace nebo že FANOUT gate by neměly
být počítány jako gate, nebo obojí,
stále bychom měli, že celočíselné sčítání lze vypočítat s náklady big-O od N.
WEBVTT
Tady je další příklad
výpočetního problému, násobení celých čísel.
Podobně jako u sčítání se můžeme zeptat, jaké jsou náklady
tohoto výpočtu.
Pokud zvažujeme standardní
algoritmus násobení, tj. dvoukou analogii metody pro násobení čísel
vyučované na základních školách,
což je v podstatě jen
posunování a sčítání při práci s čísly v binárním zápisu, zjistíme, že existují Booleovské circuit o velikosti big-O od N na druhou
pro násobení N-bitových celých čísel.
Nebudu to procházet podrobně. Samozřejmě jsou circuit trochu
složitější než ty pro sčítání, ale pokud přemýšlíš o způsobu,
jakým standardní
algoritmus násobení funguje, nemělo by to být překvapením.
V podstatě potřebujeme
provést přibližně N sčítání, každé s lineárními náklady, takže skončíme s
kvadratickými náklady celkově.
To lze generalizovat. Pokud má jedno číslo N bitů a druhé N bitů, potřebujeme circuit o
velikosti big-O od N krát M.
Zde mimochodem skutečně používáme rozšíření notace big-O, kde máme více proměnných, ale lze ji takto rozšířit,
a pokud tě
zajímají konkrétní podrobnosti, odkážu tě na obsah učebnice
pro lekci, který je opět propojen v
popisu videa.
Ve skutečnosti je možné
vynásobit dvě N-bitová celá čísla způsobem,
který je asymptoticky lepší než standardní algoritmus násobení.
Konkrétně Schönhage-Strassenův algoritmus násobení
násobí dvě N-bitová celá čísla s náklady big-O od
N krát délka N
krát délka délky N. Takže jak N roste, například na
desítky tisíc bitů,
je to vlastně efektivnější
způsob násobení, ale je komplikovaný a režie ho činí nepraktickým
pro menší čísla.
Přidejme tedy násobení
do našeho seznamu příkladů.
A pro jednoduchost uveďme náklady dané standardním algoritmem násobení, což je big-O od N na druhou.
Znovu se tedy zaměřujeme na podstatnou povahu těchto nákladů, která spočívá v tom, že škálují kvadraticky
nebo sub-kvadraticky, pokud použijeme asymptoticky lepší metody.
Můžeme také uvažovat
problém celočíselného dělení, který je na obrazovce přesně uveden.
Zde mluvíme o výpočtu podílu a zbytku, takže odpověď se skládá
z dvou celých čísel, Q a R.
Opět existuje standardní
algoritmus pro dělení a také má kvadratické
náklady a podobně jako násobení
existují ve skutečnosti asymptoticky
lepší algoritmy.
Jak tedy algoritmy NSD porovnávají?
Eukleidův algoritmus se ukazuje
mít kvadratické náklady, a to jsem měl na mysli
dříve v lekci, když jsem řekl, že NSD dokážeme vypočítat
přibližně za stejné náklady jako vynásobení dvou čísel.
Opět existují
asymptoticky lepší algoritmy podobné
sčítání a násobení,
ačkoli náklady jsou v tomto případě trochu
vyšší, alespoň pokud víme.
Zmíním ještě jeden příklad problému pro přidání do tohoto seznamu, a to modulární umocňování.
Jsou zde tři vstupní
čísla, K, M a N, a cílem je vypočítat
N na mocninu K modulo M,
což znamená zbytek
po dělení M.
Není to vůbec zřejmé, ale modulární
umocňování dokážeme vypočítat s qubitovými náklady, tj. big-O od N na třetí
pro N-bitová celá čísla.
Způsob, jak to provést, není nejprve vypočítat N na mocninu K a poté vypočítat zbytek.
Dokonce zapsání N na mocninu K by mohlo vyžadovat exponenciálně mnoho bitů, takže tento přístup nebude fungovat.
Místo toho můžeme použít algoritmus
zvaný mocninný algoritmus, který se také nazývá opakované umocňování, kde vše probíhá modulo M
a k iterativnímu umocňování a násobení způsobem,
který to vše zprovozní, používáme bity
K.
Takže tento
je dražší než ostatní, ale stále dokážeme provádět
modulární umocňování poměrně rychle na číslech
s mnoha tisíci bitů.
Jak tedy náklady těchto úloh porovnávají s celočíselnou faktorizací?
Pokud začneme jednoduše a
přemýšlíme o zkusmém dělení, kde nejprve zkontrolujeme, zda je dvě dělitel vstupního čísla
a pak zkontrolujeme tři atd., skončíme s poměrně
nákladným algoritmem, big-O od N na druhou krát
dvě na mocninu N lomeno dvěma.
Každé dělení trvá kvadratický čas a v nejhorším případě budeme muset hledat prvočíselné dělitele až po odmocninu vstupního čísla,
a odtud pochází N
děleno dvěma. Pokud jsme v tom bodě nenašli
prvočíselný dělitel, můžeme jednoduše zastavit, protože pak
musí být vstupní číslo samo prvočíslo.
To je extrémně nákladné, protože N se v tomto výrazu vyskytuje jako exponent, čímž chceme říct, že tento
algoritmus má exponenciální náklady.
Naproti tomu všechny příklady, které máme v tomto rámečku, mají to, co nazýváme polynomiálními náklady, kde N je umocněno na mocnitele,
ale tento mocnitel je vždy fixní číslo, které neroste s
délkou vstupu.
V těchto případech jsou mocnitelé
jedna, dvě a tři.
Za chvíli se vrátím k polynomiálním versus exponenciálním nákladům, ale nejprve dokončeme
to, co víme o faktorizaci.
WEBVTT
Dříve jsem zmínil
síto číselného pole, což je nejlepší
faktorizační algoritmus, který máme, pokud jde o způsob, jakým se škálují jeho náklady.
Ve skutečnosti náklady tohoto algoritmu nejsou rigorózně dokázány, protože jsou spojeny s některými otevřenými otázkami z teorie čísel,
ale předpokládá se, že má
náklady, které vypadají takto.
Tentokrát je big-O v exponentu, ale tento
detail přejdu.
Klíčový závěr je, že je výrazně lepší
než zkusné dělení, protože ačkoli se N skutečně
vyskytuje v exponentu,
je umocněno na 1/3 a to se promítá v mnohem nižších nákladech a proto tento algoritmus
zvládne čísla jako RSA250, zatímco zkusné dělení
to rozhodně nezvládne.
Stále je to ale exponenciální v tom smyslu, že mocnitel N se vyskytuje v exponentu, a tak v důsledku
stále nezvládne
čísla jako RSA1024.
Řeknu nyní trochu více o polynomiálních nákladech
versus exponenciálních nákladech.
Říkáme, že algoritmus
má polynomiální náklady, pokud jeho náklady jsou big-O od N na mocninu B,
kde B může být libovolné kladné číslo, ale klíčem je, že B musí být fixní, tj. nesmí se měnit
s tím, jak délka vstupu N roste.
Pro příklady, které jsme viděli před chvílí, tj. celočíselné sčítání, násobení, dělení, výpočet NSD
a modulární umocňování,
bylo B buď
jedna, dvě nebo tři.
Tedy to jsou všechno
algoritmy s polynomiálními náklady.
Ale když obecně říkáme polynomiální
náklady, B může být libovolné kladné číslo.
Mohlo by to být dokonce milion,
ale musí být fixní.
Jako velmi hrubá abstrakce jsou algoritmy s polynomiálními
náklady typicky považovány za efektivní algoritmy.
Je to jistě zjednodušení, ale jako hrubé vodítko si o algoritmu s
polynomiálními náklady
můžeš přemýšlet jako o takovém,
který využívá strukturu problému k nalezení řešení, na rozdíl od přístupu
hrubou silou
nebo vyčerpávajícího prohledávání
velmi velkého prostoru.
Samozřejmě, algoritmus, jehož náklady škálují jako N na milion
pro vstupy délky N,
by nebyl přiměřeně
považován za efektivní a neočekávali bychom, že ho budeme schopni spustit na velkých vstupech.
Ale přesto dokonce algoritmus s N na
milion musí dělat něco chytré, co jakýmsi způsobem odráží strukturu
problému, který řeší, aby se vyhnul exponenciálnímu škálování nákladů, které by bylo spojeno s
vyčerpávajícím prohledáváním velkého prostoru.
A v praxi je identifikace algoritmu s polynomiálními náklady skutečně jen prvním
krokem k efektivitě.
Pokud je problém důležitý
a někdo objeví první polynomiální
algoritmus pro něj, možná s velmi velkým exponentem,
můžeš být přiměřeně jist, že návrháři algoritmů
najdou vylepšení, která způsobí, že tento exponent klesne.
V podstatě si lze
představit existenci algoritmu s polynomiálními náklady
pro problém jako demonstraci proveditelnosti
řešení tohoto problému
na přiměřeně velkých vstupech, ale stále by mohlo být potřeba hodně práce k dosažení skutečné efektivity.
V teorii složitosti je typické říkat, že náklady algoritmu
škálují sub-exponenciálně, pokud jsou náklady big-O od dvě na mocninu N
na mocninu epsilon pro každé kladné reálné číslo epsilon, a pokud to není sub-exponenciální,
pak je to exponenciální, nebo to může být dokonce super-exponenciální jako dvě na dvě na N,
což je doubly exponenciální,
ale pokud výstup
není super-exponenciálně dlouhý, každý problém lze ve skutečnosti
vypočítat Booleovským circuit
s exponenciálními náklady, jak se ukazuje. Takže důležitý rozdíl zde je mezi polynomiálními
a exponenciálními náklady.
Neznáme žádné klasické algoritmy s sub-exponenciálními náklady pro
celočíselnou faktorizaci.
Například náklady síta číselného pole nejsou big-O od dvě na N na epsilon, když epsilon je 1/3 nebo méně,
takže tuto definici nesplňuje.
Je to nepochybně velmi chytrý algoritmus, ale stále je to síto a stále v podstatě prohledáváme
velmi velký prostor pro identifikaci dělitelů daného čísla.
Jak uvidíme v příští lekci, ve skutečnosti existuje polynomiální
kvantový algoritmus pro celočíselnou faktorizaci.
Shorův algoritmus má polynomiální náklady a konkrétně má qubitové náklady, podobně jako modulární umocňování.
Další třída problémů, se
kterou ses možná setkal, je třída NP-úplných problémů.
V této lekci se nebudu věnovat tomu, co jsou NP-úplné problémy, ale můžeš si je
vyhledat, pokud tě to zajímá.
Předpokládá se, že
žádný z těchto problémů nemá sub-exponenciální náklady.
To je v podstatě verze toho, co se někdy nazývá
exponenciální časová hypotéza, ale zatím nikdo nebyl schopen
přijít na to, jak to dokázat.
Ve skutečnosti ani nedokážeme, že neexistují lineární algoritmy pro NP-úplné problémy.
Je to prostě opravdu těžké, alespoň pokud víme, vyloučit možnost budoucího objevení neuvěřitelně kreativního
algoritmu pro tyto problémy.
WEBVTT
Tady je obrázek, který
ilustruje vztah mezi polynomiálními a exponenciálními náklady.
Na ose X máme délku vstupu problému, o kterém přemýšlíme, a osa Y reprezentuje
náklady na řešení tohoto problému,
nebo si to lze představit
jako čas potřebný k řešení problému.
Algoritmus s exponenciálními náklady
by mohl škálovat takto.
Pro krátké vstupy nemusí být náklady příliš vysoké, jako třeba faktorizace
čísla 12,
ale jak se délka vstupu zvyšuje, náklady se nakonec prudce zvýší.
Algoritmus s polynomiálními náklady
na druhou stranu by mohl mít škálování, které vypadá takto.
Náklady obecně porostou s tím, jak vstupy budou delší, a mohou být dokonce vyšší než náklady algoritmu s exponenciálními náklady pro některé vstupy,
ale nakonec bude
mnohem méně nákladný než algoritmus s exponenciálními náklady a neroste extrémně tak
jako algoritmy s exponenciálními náklady.
Takže pokud si představíme, že máme
nějaké maximální náklady, které jsme ochotni vynaložit, nebo maximální čas, který jsme ochotni čekat na odpověď,
pokud raději přemýšlíš v čase, pak algoritmus s exponenciálními náklady bude fungovat pouze pro vstupy
do určité délky,
zatímco obecně algoritmus
s polynomiálními náklady nám umožní řešit
problém pro větší vstupy.
A proto například dokážeme snadno vypočítat NSD pro čísla s mnoha tisíci
bitů, ale v nejhorším případě
nedokážeme faktorizovat čísla této velikosti.
V poslední části lekce se zaměříme na implementaci klasických výpočtů
na kvantových počítačích.
Konkrétněji uvidíme, že jakýkoli výpočet, který může být proveden Booleovským circuit, může být proveden také kvantovým circuit
přibližně za stejné náklady. Navíc to lze
provést čistým způsobem, který je důležitý, pokud chceme tyto výpočty spouštět
jako podrutiny uvnitř
větších kvantových výpočtů, a vysvětlím, co mám na mysli čistým, až se dostaneme dál v diskuzi.
Budeme využívat
Toffoli gate v tomto procesu.
Vzpomínáš si, že Toffoli gate jsou controlled-controlled-NOT gate, takže jejich akce na standardní bazové stavy
je taková, jak vidíš na obrazovce.
Všimni si, že o Toffoli gate si také
můžeme myslet jako o query gate
pro funkci AND.
To neznamená, že jsou to query gate v doslovném smyslu. Jak jsem zmínil na začátku lekce, v tomto bodě nepracujeme v
dotazovacím modelu,
ale jejich akce spíše sleduje stejný vzor jako query gate.
Binární hodnoty A a B si lze představit jako vstupy funkce AND a podobně jako query gate
jsou tyto hodnoty echované
jako součást výstupu a hodnota funkce, tj. logické AND A a B,
se XORuje na spodní qubit. Toffoli gate jsme nezahrnuli do naší standardní sady gate.
Mohli bychom si to rozmyslet, ale vlastně to nemusíme
udělat, protože alternativně můžeme implementovat Toffoli
gate pomocí Hadamard gate,
T a T dagger gate
a controlled NOT gate, jak vidíš tady.
Vůbec není zřejmé,
že tento konkrétní circuit implementuje Toffoli gate, ale dělá to, a buď mi to můžeš věřit,
nebo si to sám odvodit pro trochu extra praxe, nebo se prostě zeptat Qiskit nebo Pythonu
nebo jakéhokoli softwaru, který násobí matice, aby za tebe násobení provedl.
A v obsahu učebnice pro lekci si to můžeš prohlédnout provedené pomocí Qiskit.
Nyní se můžeme přesunout k simulaci Booleovských gate pomocí kvantových circuit a vše, co k tomu budeme potřebovat, jsou NOT gate,
controlled NOT gate a Toffoli gate.
Tyto operace jsou všechny deterministické, kromě toho, že jsou unitární, a někdy takovéto operace popisujeme jako reverzibilní, a ve skutečnosti
studium reverzibilních výpočtů předchází kvantovým výpočtům a odtud celý tento
postup vlastně pochází.
Booleovské gate, o které se musíme
starat, jsou NOT gate, Hadamard gate a FANOUT gate,
a co ukážeme, je, že tyto gate dokážeme implementovat nebo simulovat, chceš-li, pomocí NOT gate,
controlled NOT gate a Toffoli gate.
Jasně, chceme
kvantové circuit, které nám umožní vypočítat hodnoty Booleovských gate, které jsem právě zmínil,
když jim jako vstup dáme qubity
ve standardních bazových stavech.
Pro libovolné kvantové stavové vstupy bude akce určena
linearitou jako obvykle.
NOT gate nemusíme
nijak zvlášť řešit. NOT gate jsou NOT gate a lze je implementovat přímo.
A OR gate lze simulovat
pomocí Toffoli a NOT gate.
AND gate jsou jednoduché, zejména s ohledem na to, co jsem právě řekl před chvílí o Toffoli gate, že jsou v podstatě
query gate implementacemi
funkce AND.
Přesněji řečeno, to, co můžeme udělat, je zavést nový qubit inicializovaný do stavu nula
a nechat tento qubit být
cílem našeho Toffoli gate a nechat dva vstupní
qubity být ovladači.
Extra qubitům jako tomuto jsou dávána různá jména, která jsou často zaváděna
do kvantových výpočtů, a já je budu nazývat pracovní
qubity jen abych si vybral název.
WEBVTT
Naším typickým předpokladem pro pracovní qubity je, že začínají ve stavu nula a často je můžeme vrátit
do stavu nula,
když s nimi skončíme, ale ne vždy.
V diagramu máme ket nula uvnitř tečkovaného obdélníku, abychom naznačili, že
inicializace tohoto qubitu
je součástí procesu, a pokud nemáš
čerstvý qubit jako tento, nebudeš schopen
tuto simulaci provést.
Spodní výstupní qubit
je ten, na kterém nám záleží, protože to je výsledek
operace AND a s ostatními dvěma
máme v podstatě hotovo,
takže mohou zůstat uvnitř boxu.
Vlastně si lze dokonce představit, že zbavení se těchto dvou qubitů je součástí práce
simulace tohoto AND gate,
trochu jako odpad,
který je třeba uklidit.
Ale každopádně, takto
dokážeme simulovat AND gate.
Teď když víme, jak dělat AND gate, můžeme dělat OR gate pomocí
jednoho z De Morganových zákonů.
Pokud dáš NOT gate na dva vstupy a výstup AND
gate, dostaneš OR gate, takže to je tak jednoduché.
A poslední je FANOUT, a pro tento potřebujeme jen controlled NOT gate spolu s pracovním qubitem.
Konkrétně, pokud
nastavíme pracovní qubit jako cíl, efektivně jen zkopírujeme jakýkoli standardní bazový stav, který přijde,
takže to funguje jako FANOUT gate.
Takže máme všechny gate.
A teď když máme všechny gate, můžeme se přesunout k circuit.
Předpokládejme, že máme
nějaký Booleovský circuit nazvaný C, a to může být libovolný
Booleovský circuit dle tvé volby,
pokud se skládá z
AND nebo NOT a FANOUT gate.
Nechť T je počet gate v C a dáme jméno F funkci, kterou C vypočítá.
Takže F si lze představit jako mající tvar, který vidíš tady, kde N je počet vstupních bitů C,
M je počet výstupních bitů a sigma je binární abeceda.
A to, co uděláme, je jednoduše projít gate C jedno po druhém.
NOT gate necháme být a ostatní nahradíme simulacemi,
které jsem právě popsal.
Takže pokud C vypadá takto, pak to, co dostaneme, je circuit
R, který vypadá takto.
V tomto diagramu všechny
pracovní qubity, které potřebujeme pro simulace, byly vytaženy z jejich boxů a shromážděny dole.
K je tedy celkový počet
pracovních qubitů, které potřebujeme, což je jeden pro každé z gate C s výjimkou NOT gate.
Pro výstup R máme qubity, které
odpovídají výstupu C, a v tomto diagramu jsou tyto qubity
zobrazeny nahoře,
ačkoli ve skutečnosti na konci celého tohoto procesu
nezáleží, zda jsou nahoře nebo ne.
Přesněji řečeno, za předpokladu, že jsme spustili R na standardním bazovém stavu odpovídajícím
libovolnému N-bitovému řetězci X,
těchto M výstupních qubitů bude ve standardním bazovém stavu
odpovídajícím F(X).
Máme také všechny zbývající qubity z AND a OR gate.
Stále je musíme zaznamenat, a pokud je shromáždíme dohromady, budou v nějakém standardním bazovém stavu.
Jakýkoli standardní bazový stav to je, musí být nějakou funkcí řetězce X, a téhle funkci dáme
název G.
G je tedy nová funkce, která je
určena gate C a říká nám, v jakém stavu
jsou tyto zbývající qubity
poté, co je R spuštěno. G je písmeno po F, takže to je jeden důvod pro
pojmenování této funkce G,
ale další důvod pro pojmenování G je, že G je zkratka pro garbage (odpad).
Jsou to všechno odpadní qubity, a konkrétně máme
dva odpadní qubity pro každé AND gate a pro každé OR gate.
Celkový počet gate,
které potřebujeme, je big-O od T.
To proto, že pro každé gate C potřebujeme ohraničený počet kvantových gate.
OR gate je nejdražší. Pro ten potřebujeme tři NOT gate spolu s jedním Toffoli gate,
a Toffoli gate nás stojí 15 gate z naší standardní sady gate.
Takže to je nejvýše 18 gate
v R pro každé gate C.
Kdybys to chtěl optimalizovat, mohl bys, ale pro účely
hrubé asymptotické analýzy stačí říct, že
R má big-O od T gate.
Takže se nám podařilo
vypočítat tutéž funkci F, kterou vypočítal původní Booleovský
circuit C,
a udělali jsme to za náklady, které jsou lineární v velikosti C.
Pokud nám záleží jen
na výpočtu funkce F, pak jsme hotovi.
Bohužel ale máme
tyto odpadní qubity a tyto odpadní qubity
obecně zničí
interferenční vzory, které způsobují, že kvantové algoritmy fungují, pokud se pokusíme použít tento
circuit R jako podrutinu
uvnitř většího kvantového algoritmu.
Tohoto odpadu se ale ve skutečnosti dokážeme zbavit, a způsob, jak to provést, je využít fakt, že circuit R lze invertovat,
WEBVTT
jinými slovy, dokážeme
ho spustit pozpátku.
Pro ilustraci, jak to funguje, si představme, že nejprve spustíme R a poté spustíme R pozpátku,
což lze vyjádřit jako R dagger.
Aby bylo jasno, co to znamená: aplikujeme gate
R v obráceném pořadí a bereme inverzy
každého z gate.
NOT gate, controlled NOT
gate a Toffoli gate jsou vlastně svými vlastními inverzy, takže pokud uvažujeme v pojmech těchto gate,
pak R dagger je vlastně jen R s gate dodanými
v obráceném pořadí.
Ale obecně vždy dokážeme spustit jakýkoli unitární kvantový circuit pozpátku způsobem, který jsem právě popsal,
tj. aplikujeme gate
v obráceném pořadí a každé z jednotlivých gate
nahradíme jeho inverzí.
Kdybychom to udělali, zjistili bychom, že spuštění R nejprve a poté spuštění R
pozpátku nedělá vůbec nic.
Takže kdybychom začali ve standardním bazovém stavu jako tady, skončili bychom přesně ve stejném standardním bazovém stavu.
Dělat jen to samozřejmě
není příliš užitečné, ale co můžeme udělat, je zavést skupinu extra qubitů, a konkrétně
je to M qubitů, kde M je počet výstupních bitů circuit C.
Tyto dodatečné qubity mohou
být v libovolném kvantovém stavu, ale abychom vysvětlili, jak to funguje, budeme předpokládat, že jsou ve standardním bazovém stavu
odpovídajícím nějakému řetězci Y. Takže Y je M-bitový řetězec a to, co můžeme udělat, je provést
skupinu controlled NOT
gate, jak vidíš tady, které efektivně XORují řetězec F(X)
na řetězec Y uložený
v těchto spodních M qubitech.
A tedy výstup
celého výpočtu je takový, jak se jeví na obrazovce.
X a Y jsou libovolné binární řetězce. X má M bitů a Y má M bitů, a také potřebujeme K pracovních qubitů.
Když spustíme R, vypočítáme F(X) a tento řetězec je uložen
v horních M qubitech, ale máme také
spoustu odpadních qubitů,
takže XORujeme výstup F(X)
na spodní M qubitů a poté spustíme R pozpátku
pro uklidení odpadu.
Měl bych upozornit, že je důležité, aby R bylo deterministické.
Pokud by těchto horních M qubitů mohlo být místo toho v nějaké superpozici
standardních bazových stavů, nefungovalo by to správně,
ale toto funguje, když
R je deterministické.
Takže pokud porovnáme kvantový
circuit, který jsme právě sestrojili, s původním Booleovským circuit C, vidíme, že v podstatě
funguje stejným způsobem
jako query gate funguje
pro libovolnou funkci.
Je tu jeden rozdíl, a to, že potřebujeme
tyto pracovní qubity, aby to vše fungovalo, ale jinak jsme
efektivně sestavili query gate
nebo query circuit pro jakoukoli funkci, kterou C vypočítá.
Také se nám mimochodem podařilo vrátit pracovní
qubity do jejich počátečního stavu, takže by mohly být v principu znovu použity
jako pracovní qubity pro
následné výpočty.
Pokud chceme, můžeme dát kolem celého kvantového circuit rámeček a nazvat ho Q a vztah k
C se stává jasnějším.
Circuit Q bude
obecně větší než C. V Q potřebujeme hrstku kvantových
gate pro každé gate C,
a také potřebujeme controlled
NOT gate uprostřed, ale počet je stále
lineární v velikosti C.
Mělo by být také poznamenáno, že toto je zcela obecný postup, který funguje pro jakýkoli Booleovský circuit, a vůbec jsme se nesnažili optimalizovat Q.
Pro konkrétní circuit C může velmi dobře existovat
způsob, jak snížit velikost Q, a to zahrnuje použití metod,
které snižují počet
pracovních qubitů potřebných v případě, že to
chceme provést, a to je postup pro spouštění
klasických výpočtů
na kvantovém počítači.
Je to poměrně jednoduché, ale je to důležitá
věc, kterou je třeba umět.
Konkrétně, teď
když víme, jak to provést, máme volnost využívat jakékoli klasické výpočty,
uvnitř kvantových výpočtů, za předpokladu, že dodržujeme tento formát, kde je vstup echovaný a výstup je XORovaný
na skupinu qubitů
stejně jako jsme měli pro query gate.
Náklady škálují lineárně. Takže například dokážeme
vytvořit kvantové circuit pro problémy jako celočíselné sčítání,
násobení, dělení, výpočet NSD a modulární umocňování, a to vše lze provést za stejné asymptotické náklady
jako pro Booleovské circuit.
K tomu potřebujeme pracovní qubity, ale alespoň je lze opět znovu použít, když
s nimi skončíme.
Jedna závěrečná poznámka, která stojí za zmínku, je, že tato metoda nám poskytuje metodu pro implementaci query gate,
na kterou jsem narazil v předchozí lekci.
na kterou jsem narážel v předchozí lekci.
To jest, pokud máme dotazovací algoritmus, který bere jako vstup nějakou funkci F, a máme způsob, jak
F vypočítat Booleovským circuit,
pak můžeme postupovat podle tohoto postupu k sestavení query gate pro tuto funkci a poté na ní spustit náš dotazovací algoritmus.
Zda je to užitečné udělat, závisí na dotazovacím problému samotném a na tom, čeho se snažíme dosáhnout, ale v podstatě tato
konstrukce nám poskytuje
způsob propojení dotazovacího modelu s více standardním modelem výpočtu.
Toto je v jistém smyslu způsob, jakým funguje Shorův algoritmus pro celočíselnou faktorizaci.
WEBVTT
Sestrojíme
kvantové circuit jako tento z některých aritmetických operací, o kterých jsme mluvili dříve v lekci.
A tím dáme
kvantovým circuit schopnost vyhodnocovat tyto operace na superpozicích klasických stavů.
A jak uvidíme, to nám umožní efektivně faktorizovat celá čísla.
To je konec této lekce, která se zaměřovala hlavně na vytvoření základu
pro kvantové algoritmy ve standardním ne-black-box
výpočetním rámci.
Mluvili jsme o výpočetních nákladech hlavně skrze optiku problémů spojených se základní teorií čísel.
Diskutovali jsme o polynomiálních
versus exponenciálních nákladech pro výpočetní úlohy a viděli jsme, jak klasické výpočty
mohou být implementovány kvantovými circuit čistým způsobem bez odpadu, který jim umožňuje být používány jako podrutiny
uvnitř větších kvantových výpočtů.
Doufám, že se připojíš k příští lekci, kde uvidíme, jak Shorův algoritmus tyto myšlenky využívá a umožňuje nám faktorizovat
celá čísla s polynomiálními náklady.
Nashledanou.